Tonight I was working with a
friend at a food stall and
we were talking about getting ready to close
and it
all got dark when we heard some
rockets that weren't rockets
we heard some gunshots and well
and I didn't know it was gunshots I was 15
years old at the time  when I was
working
in the neri one round
and
and my friend also we don't know anything but
the good thing is that a man who was
working and with us was in the
marine or in the army I don't remember
much which one he was but he told us the guy
of a pistol that was
shooting at us and they took out the grips and the
hooks
and we wanted them to leave but everything was
everything was full of people
and I was
plotting what was happening I
didn't know what to think
and thank God I went out and I went out but  I lost
my friend when we wanted to go out because
where we work with everyone they
got hold of us from there they didn't
tell us how to exit stones
and when I went out I saw a man who was in
front of me  that many
people shot him if they wanted to help him just like
me I wanted to help him too and we
helped him there we took him to Reuters
and hired him there they gave him help
but since I didn't know where
the two bullets were coming I left because I
had  many things in mind that I did not know
what to think and I left the Reuters casino
and from there I was already lost I did not know
where to go and I left the script or is he
I went back that if not my
phone was at a percent
I called  to my mom but I didn't know where it
was
I didn't know the directions and a
man from an uber or a taxi was there I don't
remember which one it was and my mom told her
which one was which where it was and everything
later my phone ran out of  battery
and I was sitting I was thinking about everything
as I said I was 15 years old I knew nothing about
the streets I knew nothing
and
but more night in my life because how
I found this company here
the insistent well first I was in a I
was giving therapies called  maba
you live in counseling and
they helped me find
a company called veal that
also gave me a lot and they had a
worker called marita
and she contacted me with that
company here that not only helped me
but also helped me  My family,
I want to thank this company
that helped everyone who was at that
event, well, it was so guaranteed, well,
everyone who is afraid to get
help here at the Big Strong Center, here
we grab them with open hands for
everyone who has  fear them
if they are ready to listen to their
stories they are ready to help you in
any way you need well all
my condolences goes to all those who
were in the shooting all those who were not
on point
to their families
I give all my condolences and to all
those who  survived makes these
moments very hard for everyone
else
still needs to start from this